Parsing is done when dividing data into
parts based on some kind of delimiter.
For comma separated values file or a CSV
file, the data is delimited with commas.
When opened in
an application like Excel or
Alteryx, the comma is used
to separate the fields.
We might come across files that
have different delimiters though,
like the pipe symbol, or a tilde symbol.
Regardless of what delimiter is used,
it needs to be a character
that's not usually found in the data so
that when it's used to parse fields,
it will not pull fields of
data apart unexpectedly.
Now that we know a little
more about what parsing is,
let's explore a few examples.
In this first example, two values are
embedded in the data in one field and
separated by a period.
The period can be used
to delimit the data,
thereby splitting the data
in to three fields.
One containing the word data, the second
containing the first number, and
the third the second number.